Matthew is with us in Oklahoma hi
Matthew welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
better than I deserve sir how can I help
all righty well I called you about two
years ago about some college advice and
I followed it and I'm in college now
good but I've hit a road bump that I'm
not sure how I'm gonna get over so
hopefully you can help me so when my
grandparents passed away on my mom's
side
my mom inherited the money and what had
happened was is that the money they
inherited counted as income and so for
inherited money is not income um so I
got a letter in the mail so I'm from
Oklahoma and Oklahoma has a program
called Oklahoma's promise that pays
tuition and they said that because of
the increase in income that some
inherited money is not income I I don't
know it's not I dunno so um I'll talk
with my parents about that about that
and like tell them that you said that I
love to bring it up lightly your name is
a bad word in my house and so like the
the problem that I'm having is that I'm
disqualified right now for aid that I
get from the state so my university
costs about 23,000 a semester and I got
it down to about 2,300 and after the
scholarship it brings it up to about
4,300 and I'm able to go through college
debt-free but the problem that I'm
having is that losing this scholarship
is I can probably make it till the end
of the semester and then I run out of
money for next semester so your
not working so I am working but um the
the scholarship that I had I made enough
money to pay my way through the semester
but after losing about the scholarship I
understand you correctly when you said
you have $4,300 that you need per year
after losing the scholarship yeah okay
thirty thousand three hundred dollars
per year per semester
Oh per semester okay so yeah
twenty-three thousand a semester and I
got it down to well after the
scholarship lost forty three hundred a
semester okay so you need nine thousand
dollars a year so you need to make a
thousand dollars a month it's your job
yeah and so with the jobs that I have I
work about four I get our three and two
is regular pay and then one is every
quarter but the problem is is that I
only have about two about 2,400 in my
bank account right now is that like I
don't have enough money income life to
make it through the year let alone the
other two years that I have left okay do
you have a car I do but my parents won't
let me sell it because it's still under
their name okay I wasn't going to sell
it I was going to have you deliver
pizzas every night and make $1,500 a
month $1,500 a month solves this problem
easily yeah um that is sort of the thing
like I was thinking about it but all of
my professors are wanting to be against
it unless your professors are going to
start writing you checks I don't give a
crap what your professors opinions are
yeah that makes a lot of sense
hey there under tenure yeah there are
you know like take out the minimum I
need I'm studying instrumental music
education
okay yeah well listen if you want to go
through school you're gonna have to have
the money to do it and the only place I
know where money comes from if it's not
coming from scholarships at work and
you're not gonna you're not making any
money at the jobs you're doing so you
know your professors once you quit
school now your professors once you go
into that oh they don't care they're you
stay by going in debt because they're in
debt and they're stupid
so no I if I'm in your shoes dude I'm
delivering pizzas and I'm gonna pay my
bill and keep going you've just about
made it over the top of this thing
you're almost done you can see the light
you're you know the good news is you
don't have a $50,000 problem you have a
$5,000 problem
it's very solvable you can do that
beautifully so good luck with it I hope
you turn it around I hope you can to go
do it but that's what I would do if I
were in your shoes